a lot of you out there watching are
parents you know the ups and downs of
dealing with children they throw
tantrums make messes and can drive you
crazy
your kids will hit you up for money beg
you for a ride somewhere and make you
late for more events than you can
remember but every once in a while as
parents we get to flip the script and
use our kids as an excuse to not do
something
have a family barbecue you don't want to
attend oh sorry my kid's sick got to
stay home
asked to stay late at work can't gotta
rush home daughter's got a recital son's
got a football game
but if you're the speaker of the house
you get to use children as an excuse to
stay in congress well past your
expiration date
because yesterday nancy pelosi made this
announcement
when people ask me what are the three
most important issues facing the
congress i always say the same thing our
children our children our children that
is my why why i am in congress for the
children
this is my story and this is my song as
you hear me say
when you're in the arena you have to be
able to take a punch or throw a punch
for the children
that is why i am running for re-election
to congress
that's right nancy pelosi at age 81 is
running for re-election she says she's
doing it for the children but whose
children exactly
her own children
paul pelosi jr is 52 years old and let's
just say he and hunter biden would get
along really well
he's been tied up in a ton of shady
business that federal agents are digging
into
is she clinging to power to protect
little pauly p
perhaps
and we'll have a special report tomorrow
on the offspring of the most powerful
democrats in washington
but paul her baby boy isn't the only
reason nancy won't let go of power
there's still a lot of money to make
i'm not leaving
i'm not leaving
i'm not leaving
[Applause]
nancy isn't running to help the children
she's running to help herself
and she's made a career doing just that
pelosi first entered congress in 1987
and since then she's built herself quite
a bank account she's become one of the
wealthiest members of congress with
assets as high as
315 million dollars
a lot of scratch for a public servant
making less than six digits for three
decades so
how did she become so rich
as usual in washington this was a family
affair
her husband paul is a businessman who
may enjoy a little pillow talk with his
wife the speaker of the house paul
pelosi senior has had a history of
perfectly timed stock trades while his
wife has been running the people's house
in march of last year he pulled off a
two million dollar microsoft trade
just two weeks before the company got a
22 billion dollar contract to sell the
army high tech headsets
in december 2020 paul and nancy got a
million dollars worth of tesla stock
options
right before biden announced electric
car incentives
and in june the pelosi family cashed in
big time just as congress was debating
what to do with big tech
making a cool
5 million from google's parent company
so while nancy slow walks anti-trust
legislation to break up big tap her
family taking advantage and laughing all
the way to the bank
they must think we're idiots
because just look at the tech companies
your family's still invested in
apple tesla
amazon microsoft
the list goes on and on and on
maybe this is why pelosi defended
congress's right to trade stocks last
month
she didn't want to kill the golden goose
should members of congress and their
spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks while serving the
congress no i don't know to the second
one we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
this isn't new back in 2011 60 minutes
pressed her pretty hard on the same
thing when she raked in millions from a
sweetheart visa credit card ipo watch
madam leader um
i wanted to ask you why you and your
husband back in march of 2008 um
accepted and participated in a very
large ipo deal from visa at a time there
was major
legislation affecting their credit card
companies making its way through the um
through the house
and did you consider that to be a
conflict of interest
i don't know what your point is of your
question is there some point that you
want to make with that well i guess what
i'm asking is do you think it's all
right for uh a speaker uh to accept uh a
very preferential and favorable uh stock
deal well we did it you participated in
the ipo
and at the time you were speaker of the
house you don't think it was a conflict
of interest or had the appearance of a
conflict
it only has appearance if you decide
that you're going to have a a elaborate
on a false premise but it it's not true
and that's that i don't understand what
part's not true
yes sir
that i would act upon an investment
how dare anybody question her honor and
integrity
everyone in congress is doing it anyway
last year members of congress traded
about 300 million dollars in stocks and
assets and guess what
they all outperform the market
pelosi is just the best at it
if nancy wasn't writing laws she'd
probably run a hedge fund the wolf of
washington
run for congress and you too could buy
some extravagant properties like this
napa valley mansion nancy and paul
bought worth about 25 million dollars or
a gorgeous waterfront condo in
washington dc
that pelosi property now worth over two
mil
or the family's multi-million dollar red
brick mansion in california's pacific
heights
could be yours if you just spend your
whole life in washington playing the
inside game
and while the pelosi's are living the
high life in swanky homes her district
is turning into the thunderdome
welcome
to another edition of thunder now
just look at this drone footage courtesy
of the dailymail.com
showing a homeless encampment in the
center of san francisco
there he has been overrun with tents
needles
drug addicts
and this is the district
of the leader of the congressional
democrats
maybe nancy could invest more in her
district instead of her portfolio
if nancy dumped a few shares she could
help make san francisco less of a dump
a little goes a long way just a few
crumbs
instead she'll continue to be the warren
buffett of washington
that is until you the american people
step up and you have
the heat's on the speaker and suddenly
she's flip-flopped
now
now she thinks congress may have to rein
in the day trading watch
i trust our members if in fact we should
have severe
penalties for delay and reporting on
stock act then do that you give a
blanket
attitude of
we can't do this and we can't do that
because we can't be trusted i just don't
buy into that but if members want to do
that i'm okay with it
that's right nance promise to stop once
you get caught
we asked nancy pelosi for comment and
here's what she said
the point is ladies and gentlemen
that greed
for lack of a better word
is good greed is right sorry that was
the wrong tape the speaker has not yet
responded to our inquiry
but when it's not about the money it's
usually about the power this morning we
found out liberal justice stephen breyer
may be retiring from the supreme court
leaving biden to pick a replacement
so if joe picks kamala
that would create a vacancy in the vice
presidency this would leave nancy pelosi
an opening to invoke
the 25th amendment and remove biden from
office
guess who takes over as
commander-in-chief you guessed it nancy
pelosi up president pelosi
now that theory is bonkers and will
likely never happen i admit we're just
exercising our constitutional
imagination hey
if we can't get away with insider
training at least
let us have a little fun hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else